c'était il y a quatre ans le 2 décembre
2018 un homme ouvre le feu à l'hôpital
Trousseau de Tours il est venu en
découdre avec son ex-compagne infirmière
au sein de l'établissement par chance
personne n'est blessé mais l'individu
est toujours dit poursuivi pour
tentative demeure son process est ouvert
lundi devant la cour d'assistes
d'Indre-et-Loire résumé de cette
deuxième journée de témoignage avec
Florent Clavel
je vais vous fumer bande de bâtards à la
barre un vigile raconte cette fraction
de seconde où il s'est vu mourir il est
5h30 ce matin du 2 décembre 2018 devant
l'entrée de l'IRM de l'hôpital Trousseau
de Chambray-lès-Tours Adrien grille une
cigarette avec un collègue et deux
employés en radiologie la victime
toujours il court vers nous il hurle je
vais vous fumer bande de bâtards son
armée levée à hauteur d'homme il est à 3
mètres on recule il tire adrien a juste
eu le temps de reconnaître cet homme
très énervé qu'il avait reconduit à
l'entrée des urgences un quart d'heure
auparavant en cause une violente
altercation verbale avec sa femme
infirmière aux urgences il conclut pour
moi il voulait nous tuer Stéphane
l'accusé tireur dans un club de
Montlouis-sur-Loire jure que non et par
chance personne ne sera blessé écouter
les précisions de son avocate mon client
ça va faire quatre ans maintenant qu'il
claque son innocence sur cette intention
de de tuer et nous notre tête bien
évidemment ce qu'on essaye de marteler
et ce qu'on va continuer de marteler
jusqu'à la fin de ce procès c'est quand
il s'est rendu à l'hôpital cette nuit-là
ce n'était pas pour donner la mort et
encore moins à ses agents de sécurité
qui étaient derrière ce coup de feu la
suite la panique des infirmières et
dépasse si on urgences et le forcené qui
déambule et mettent en jouent un
aide-soignant avant de renoncer à son
projet et de s'enfuir quels étaient ces
intentions finales que voulait-il
infliger à la mère de ses enfants
infirmière au CHU de moi par avant lui
avait avoué sa liaison avec un collègue
plongeant le couple dans une crise
profonde voulait-il se suicider devant
elle comme il le soutiendra en garde à
vue la suite du procès le dira sur son
coup de folie l'homme de 45 ans devrait
s'exprimer ce soir ou demain matin pour
tentative de meurtre violence volontaire
avec usage ou sous la menace d'une arme
et violence conjugale l'accusé en cours
30 ans de prison